[Musique]
historique revue de presse nouvelle
formule avec vous et hélène frade
bonjour hélène bonjour pauline une revue
de presse spéciale évidemment consacrée
aux funérailles d'état de comme dans une
série d' andy warhol qui avait
d'ailleurs réalisé son portrait le
visage d'une voix de feu elizabeth ii se
répète à l'infini ce matin à la une des
quotidiens britanniques sur fond noir
sur fond violet le visage de la
souveraine souriante vêtue d'une tenue
bleu ciel bleu tourterelles plus
précisément et portant une broche que
lui avait offerte son père le roi george
vi auquel paraît-il elle était très
attachée
cette photo inédite date de mai dernier
elle a été diffusée hier par buckingham
palace ce sourire va nous manquer god
bless que dieu bénisse la reine titre ce
matin dawson au revoir à notre glorieuse
rennes titre ce matin de son côté le
daily express alors que notre nation se
prépare à accompagner la reine dans sa
dernière demeure heureux nous nous
souvenons d'elle heureuse et glorieuse
écrit le daily mirror tandis que le
daily telegraph
et bien remercier elizabeth ii pour
avoir consacré toute sa vie ou presque à
son pays il vit totalement dévoué au
service du royaume uni
remerciements partagé également par le
grec le gratuit métro
merci madame le quotidien gratuit a
choisi lui un portrait datant de 1955 en
été deux ans après le couronnement d 2
le royaume uni point d'exclamation
peut-être le daily star à propos de
l'hommage silencieux corps ont dû encore
cette nuit un des milliers et les
milliers de britanniques à londres à
leur souveraine unis dans le deuil
peut-être mais pour combien de temps le
royaume uni est un tournant annonce
veine dependence qui rappelle que
certaines parties du royaume uni attend
d'elle décès de la souveraine pour
exprimer leur volonté d'indépendance des
velléités de séparation auxquelles devra
faire face l'héritier et d'elizabeth ii
le roi charles iii qu'on retrouve à la
une du times accueillant à bras ouverts
la nouvelle première ministre les
strauss en tenue de deuil un deuil vous
l'avez évoqué qui va être partagée dans
le monde entier aujourd'hui notamment
par des représentants des centaines de
représentants près de 500 dirigeants de
la planète réunis aujourd'hui à
westminster des dirigeants dont la
présence simultanée à londres clovis
casali l'a évoqué déclenché la plus
grosse opération de sécurité de
l'histoire du royaume uni et c'est ce
que rappelle ce matin le quotidien
hommage également hélène bien sûr un des
dessinateurs de presse britannique un
voyage circonstances exceptionnelles
dessin particulier les dessinateurs à
britanniques ou un peu perdu de leur
mordant ce matin et ont choisi optez
plutôt pour le symbolisme comme dans ce
dessein de bauer ou le saphir de la
couronne brille de milles ce le royaume
uni se trouve au coeur de ce saphir la
pierre précieuse et or de la couronne
royale
alors la couronne et les attributs de la
royauté les retrouve aussi dans le
dessein de bendjé knicks qui les a
intégrés dans ce qu'on appelle une
vanité un tableau allégorique qui
représente la mort très symbolique aussi
ses dessins de gamme body qui représente
le voile le drapeau de l'union jack avec
un trou au milieu
profil de la reine elizabeth 2 mai le
plus émouvant sans doute en tout cas
selon moi il est signé morton moerlen
pour le times et il montera en le voit
l'absence le vide laissé par elizabeth
ii les funérailles de la haine ce de la
reine pardon sont évidemment à la une de
plusieurs quotidiens français également
alors le parisien aujourd'hui en france
évoque les obsèques du siècle un
événement historique qui pourrait
attirer deux millions de personnes dans
les rues de la capitale britannique et
être suivi par près de 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs dans le monde entier
notamment sur france24 bien évidemment
une cérémonie pour l'histoire dont le
quotidien parisien détail le déroulement
dans cette infographie très détaillé
avec tout d'abord le transfert du
cercueil vers l'abbaye de westminster la
cérémonie à proprement parler à laquelle
on l'a dit près de deux mille personnes
assisteront puis la procession à travers
londres puis enfin le dernier mode au
revoir à windsor le figaro lui se
concentre sur la dimension à la fois
international et diplomatique de
l'événement avec ce commentaire plus de
mille invitations et était postée mais
le russe vladimir poutine dans a pas
reçus se retrouve relégué je cite en
compagnie de paria de l'acabit les
talibans afghans du boucher syrien assad
et de la junte birmane au pays de la
révolution française évidemment la pompe
et le faste à font grincer pas mal de
dents l'humanité quotidien communiste
observe que le nouveau souverain charles
iii va se retrouver à la tête d'un
royaume des unis sur un adia monarchique
je cite ce coup et de tempêtes l'irlande
et l'ecosse a notamment aspirants on l'a
dit à retrouver leur indépendance
le gratuit 20 minutes rappelle quant à
lui n'a qu'un certain nombre de
britanniques et ne sont pas très ému par
ces funérailles royales comme en
témoignent des habitants du quartier de
camden à londres que le journal a
rencontré des sujets de sa majesté qui
expriment leur indifférence royal elle
car d'elisabeth 2 enfin libération
revient sur la mise à l'arrêt de tout le
pays puisque ce lundi a été décrété jour
férié au terme de onze jours de deuil
national
la libération qui publie ce dessin de
coco laquelle je laisserai le mot de la
fin il ya presque autant de que qu'est
la banque alimentaire en 10 des milliers
de britanniques réunies rassemblés
autour du cercueil d'elisabeth deux
allusions évidemment à la crise
économique qui frappe de plein fouet le
royaume uni
hélène merci